sono ritornato dopo un botto che non lo
facevo su venerdì 13 è con che partita
son tornato non avete idea
nel video c'è anche sasha fa scassare la
rieter regalo una visione facciamo i
culi mamma mia di soprattutto carico se
vai partiamo scanniamo gli altri se
faccio io jason ti scanu senza problemi
ma è bene grazie
siamo subito di tredici sono a livello
13 chios a livello 13 perfetta parti
prevenuto di così
ciao russia dove il papa peppa pig e
russo è vero e proprio bello e supporto
come potrei essere io
se quel gesù
però forse sì io sono sempre molto bene
anche tu non lo sai no mi resta che
chiude a questa mia mamma io sono una
bella castana con la gonna see a queste
gonnesa
io mi impegnero al massimo sapido va
bene va bene mi piace allora vogliamo
sederci a trovare più o meno il punto
dove dovreste essere mira brutta provato
anche la ragazza io chiamai io ho fatto
come hai usato che ti uccido la famiglia
come hai osato slap armi la faccia o non
vogliono vedere nelle vene tenente lena
nell'uomo chiudo nella magica vacca
ma siete tutti in queste cose ed eccomi
giorno anzi a questo sfondo alle porte
mi sa e non morellina cagata ha per
sfondo sfondo battere via aiuto mancato
scavo ansa shama che mirage fai da te si
no
[Musica]
becca del suo contenuto mancato o se
dietro uno sembra passato la mazza ma
come e cazzola lesbico
ma cosa che ho fatto già constatati
appunto aveva fatto non lo so non lo so
maiuscola mi sono chiesta ma con la
mazza mi rompe le palle per i cell mi è
vero che salva una trappola per terra io
ti consiglio di mettere due trappole
dalla macchina eh eh si lo sai ragione
devono riuscire a uscire potrete abbiamo
attraversato un è morto o che ha
assassinato bene ai ragazzi e hanno i
superpoteri ve lo giuro hanno sì ma che
vuoi ma siamo che stai guidando ameriqua
scappa ai 1600 buttato fortissima
contestare ma ricordo questo qua non è
ancora capito questo si butta fuori la
finestra come mi vede ma che è stata
fare a aiuto aiuto
sì ma no lui è scemo per pensare di
fottermi così solo perché non vengo di
la fame si essendo mai mago mai quando
lascio lesbico quando fratello ma allora
fa bene a morire a marzo nostra casa
no ha fracassato l'auto è successo
lorenzo guardi etti di prosciutto è il
te ne faccio 20th ma si sa poco
e allora questo qui se te lo mangio è un
casino come deve andare a dieta sacino
helsing un giorno avrei bisogno di
sacino permettono di una passeggiata
provocati vi vado all aiuto lorenzino
cha cha cha a queste donne
giochiamo al tiro al bersaglio che vedo
in tanto a mazzarri hanno chiamato con
un fiocco è estremo la pula vaio con
l'arco la visione vedo tutti attraverso
i muri una roba l'atroce io banche sono
tutti insieme si rivedono tutti dice mi
oro sono ancora siamo stati sempre di
uno sono ancora lascia uno che la
batteria si tu no no non sei da massimo
non solo sempre la giocherà face che
possano amare
ma io ho preso uno a caso spero sembra
non sentire anche non sia tu voglio te
nati per ultimo ma scusami di mio nonno
sto imparando con l'amico che è sfociato
prima stai bene no credo che non stia
bene
ciao zio quanta gente che ci aspetta è
uno che male che si è fatto questo
voglio già fra te e taranto
informatizzando gente su gente sta
demolendo tutto cioè ragazzi sto facendo
assassini sosta se tu sei uno degli
ultimi esisto bravo ma no io adesso ti
investo brutto bastardo perché le
macchine faccia o perché la macchina ma
veramente ma io vi dico non sapevo essi
la macchina a gemere dimenticato ce l'ha
ma la maledizione dei ragazzi
prendiamo la più alternativa al bosco
madonna che state facendo è roba brutta
sto vedendo aiuto perché così veloce che
come quel piscina per chi sismica la
quale perché sono un ottimo guidatore
lorenzo non è capito cioè io sono anni e
anni che ha proprio tu fai la retro non
è che ci provi maschera di gesù come
fosse un santino no e mi sa che devi
schiantarti o basso in mezzo al bosco
uno dei vivai dai ragazzi
ecco al giorno faccio io io prendo
questo signora qua salve perché sei
vestita come la mia ex
cosa succede qua aia chiama sparato ti
ha causato spararmi portato gli amici
allora
vado ammazza gli altri non te a
tranquillo a te ti tengo per ultimo ho
capito chiamare che occhio che per papi
che è tornata la macchina è con calma e
signorina una passeggiata
ecco bene una passeggiata proprio ora
dio ma doveri sono qua quando andate
male ciao ragazzi allora tu devi
smettere i vestiti come la mia ex necchi
la vasca di morire o reagan umore questo
è la pole al potere della bat on line
umore e io sono tipo taxi io ti ho
portato altri clienti prego gesto va
bene tutto questo tu non ti muovi non
puoi non fa il tassista consiliari hoc
che arrivata la puglia è già di altra
natura è arrivata la poule e ti dico
vabbè giustamente ti dovrei dire dovere
ma tranquilla tranquilla realtà marzo
niente aspetta è questo che visto che
sto pagando quegli otto nella parte
18enne la parte in basso a destra la
polizia che avrei risparmiato per questo
aiuterà si sa ma lo vedo in realtà
allora ascolta minore che se tu hai la
macchina ma può andare dove vuoi
[Musica]
ho visto la scena più bella da quando
gioco questa roba
e questo basta meriti di vincere veri
tira vittoria
vai entra entra e fuggi senato
l'avana sono ancora qui con lo volevo
volevo vederla pura eresia
homy ha superato la pula ma dai che
figata fu ucciso ma poi scusami questo
gli è venuto il russo ha praticamente
stavo dicendo la puglia può uccidere
gesù stai zitto sto parlando
l'aru la sola come una donna di dio la
primula pucci del genere una curva no lo
ferma e basta per si rialza messaggio un
bene di te lo giuro bellissimo quindi è
stato bello ritornare nei panni di quel
ragazzone con la lama gigante vi piace
essere jason mi piace perché la gente si
caga addosso e questo mi mi rende felice
spero ragazzi ha capito che sia piaciuto
cose si vive giornalmente mi piace anche
varese sannino descrizione sono severi
si schieri e non ci vediamo da ragazzi
[Musica]